the most important thing there is to
know your partner you really be neat to
be confident and business strategy of
those with whom you're investing it's
very difficult to invest all alone in
China it's very important to have a
reliable partner part of that is
relationship with the central government
of China and the local governments and
part of it is trust it's difficult to
work out disagreements in China's courts
so you really need to trust with whom
you're working and be confident that
their business plan has a good shot of
course there's risk everywhere but I
think those are the keys that we've been
told about well first of all capital
markets are to a large extent closed you
can't simply inject capital into China's
economy right now without permission
from the government so that's the first
hurdle that you need to get over is to
get permission to invest and then once
you're you get through that you know
they're the the key concerns are the
ones that I mentioned earlier investing
with a trusted partner and a business
plan that makes a lot of sense of course
having a business plan that doesn't run
counter to the interests of the
government is very important in China
because it's not a completely open free
market like it is in the United States
the Chinese use the expression state
directed capitalism which means that the
state does play a significant role in
the economy and if you should run cross
purposes with the intentions of the
government you may find yourself in
difficulty
I'll give you one example in the United
States when when a firm borrows money in
debt capital markets investors are very
aware that if the firm is risky that
either you don't lend it money or if you
do you lend it at a very high interest
rate and the result of that is that
capital gets allocated to firms with the
best business plans in China that hasn't
been working so well for two reasons
number one for whatever reason default
is considered an extremely adverse
result in China relative to the US and
when a corporation gets into trouble
either its local government or the
central government is very prone to bail
it out which means that if I'm an
investor in corporate bonds I don't
really care all that much about which
bonds I invest in most of them are gonna
pay off anyway and that means that
companies with the best business plans
have not a very very big advantage
relative to companies that don't really
have a good business plan at all the
second reason I'm interested in it is
that China has a only a very nice and
bond market in the United States roughly
two-thirds of corporate credit is
provided through securities markets in
China it's just a tiny tiny fraction
shockingly China has as much corporate
debt as the United States but only a
tiny tiny fraction of it is obtained
through bond markets and that means that
it's not going to be possible for China
to continue to grow at the rate it has
been or anything closed unless it
develops a very effective bond market
because as corporations get larger and
larger they can't rely only on bank
loans they need access to bond markets
as well to get cheap enough capital
in China there are four large banks
they're kind of analogous to our
JPMorgan and Citibank Bank of America
Goldman Sachs and Wells Fargo except
these large these four largest banks in
China are more than half owned by the
central government and if in order to be
a CEO of one of these four largest banks
you need to be selected by the Chinese
Communist Party and you end up having a
sub ministerial rank or vice ministerial
rank in the Chinese government you're
actually a member of the government so
that when time comes to decide to whom
you're going to lend money phone call
from a government official might be very
very influential and I think you might
have you'd be surprised if you heard
that Jamie Dimon or Lloyd Blankfein
would simply pick up the phone and make
a loan to to someone that at the
suggestion of someone in the United
States administration it doesn't work
that way in this country so that that's
uh that's another example of when you
you look at the bank and you know it has
a CEO it has a board of directors it has
equity it has debt it operates as a
corporation with public shareholders and
yet it's as much a part of the
government as it is part of financial
markets as a as a private actor
a former senior partner at Goldman Sachs
was interviewed in by Bloomberg and
recalled that in 1990 he suggested that
Japan which was the rising economic
superpower would not succeed they would
its growth would stop and it would have
difficulties perhaps financial crises
and he turned out to be right now he's
saying the same thing about China and
questioning whether this would be
superpower will be able to continue to
grow and will be able to avoid a
significant financial crisis he didn't
put any hard facts on that he said it
was a hunch he was very humble about it
but if you don't try to look at the
facts examine the numbers understand by
talking to people what's actually going
on you would be significantly influenced
by buying those kinds of suggestions
that China is is heading for serious
difficulty I have a kind of moderate
view on that I think China will be able
to have a soft lending
I had a sustainable growth rate of you
know somewhere between five and seven
percent it'll be able to pivot towards
its consumption sector hopefully it'll
be able to reduce the terrible air
pollution that its major cities has and
it'll be able to open up its capital
markets and eventually American
investors or European investors will be
able to go into China just as Chinese
investors will be able to freely invest
elsewhere that vision has been on
everyone's mind for everyone that
watches developments infinite in a
global financial system that vision has
been on their minds for a decade and it
still seems just over the horizon
will we ever actually get to that point
I don't know I think that's a it's a big
question mark but I'm I'm somewhat
optimistic that it's a question of time
and the question of success for this
kind of gradualist policy of trying one
thing after another
and hoping that enough of these things
work that that this sort of progress can
be made